whether you love it hate it or never
thought about it chances are some nanny
wants to ban it presenting the nanny of
the month runners-up the University of
wisconsin-stevens point which may ban
alcohol in dorms even for students of
legal drinking age in the city of
Chicago for officials bust food trucks
that operate within 200 feet of any non
mobile business that serves food even
convenience stores the Institute for
justice recently filed a lawsuit
targeting the new regulation which the
city enforces by tracking food trucks
with GPS devices and speaking of
tracking check out the nanny of the
month teens and parents and Texas are
not too happy about a new program that
requires students to wear electronic
tracking chips at school San Antonio's
Northside School District is testing a
radio frequency identification tracking
system higher attendance equals more
state funding and that's why officials
are eager to monitor students who are on
campus but not in their seats for roll
call if we can show that in fact they
were at school then we can count them
president the so called smart cards may
eventually track all of the districts
ninety seven thousand students check
back next month for more examples of
busybodies minding your own business